they signed up to serve and now UNLV is
helping serve them with a new course
yeah this course helps veterans
transition into college from active duty
and it's already making a difference
Candace Charles is live at UNLV this
morning with the impact that's being
made Candace good morning to you
good morning YouTube good morning folks
I don't know if you remember but
colleagues can it be some of the best
moments in your life the veterans here
tell me that this new course is helping
them get that Real Running Rebels
college experience now it's designed to
help veteran and active service students
find a sense of comfort confidence and
belonging now the three credit one hour
course is within the College of
Education it is covered by the GI Bill
and fulfills both the Multicultural and
second year seminar general education
requirements but the most important part
is a discussion based course that helps
students feel comfortable with
interacting with other students and
truly integrate in both civilian and
college life
and so a lot of our students are
learning how to collaborate and active
learning Real Time how to manage
yourself maybe step back a little bit if
if that helps quieter students come into
the discussion you get to tone it down a
little bit you get to
as Michael would call it a tactical
Retreat and you just have a chance to
explore and like let your mind be free
yeah certainly so now um Ellie is one of
the few schools in the country to offer
such a course this course is in its
inaugural semester right now it's only
being offered to transfer students but
next fall it'll also be offered to
freshman students we'll have more
details on our website 8 News now.com
for now live from UNLV I'm Candace
Charles Ables now